we're here with Grandmaster Yuri
Schulman pass us champion Yuri last year
during the championship you had your
first child and became a father can you
focus more on chess this time I hope so
yeah because the year was a little tough
for me and probably Victoria already
mentioned as you say but I hope you
Gabriel is going to help us and have a
good omen so when you're woken up in the
middle of the night you get the chess
board out when you can't back to get
back to sleep I don't know you'll see
how but definitely you know like he'll
be our moral support and will you be
helping Victoria prepare for her games
or no of course I will definitely give
you some advices and differential
factors to help as much as I can
well the last two years we've seen the
same tournament ending you and God are
playing it out why do you play so well
at the US Championships why are you
always there at the end I wouldn't say
that I played so particularly well last
year but just the result I was lucky
enough to be number two again so this
year if you at the end of the tournament
we say that you've played well will
really mean at this time because it's a
simple round round right absolutely and
should you end up in your third
consecutive tiebreaker with God ah
that's what maintenance what will you
change the next I don't know yeah
probably then no one would want organize
this event anymore it would be so
predictable or we just start with you
two and yeah but it's extremely hard I
can tell you is it like to be twice you
know like the the person who would be
deciding who would be the winner it's
still very hard so like you know what
happened again absolutely amazing and
also very unexpected for me and how many
more years before your son Gabriel gets
introduced to the game I mean what he
already tries to move pieces you know
like he already made his first MOOC in
Japan on a chess board but the only
problem
illegal so the Ovation prefers illegal
movement
well good luck very obviously you do
well thank you always happy to see you
the championship yes I think this is
always fun for both of us